welcome again everyone back to the
Council of corporate April Fool's jokes
it's great to see uh so many familiar
faces we don't have all day Jenkins all
right all right what's your pitch Fisher
Price baby's first cubicle hilarious
harmless no one gets hurt again that is
the key here I've got mine ready yeah
Criterion go we pretend Kindergarten Cop
has entered the collection nice very
harmless and fun dig at that beloved
film thank you can I go uh yeah what
company do you represent we tell
everyone they're gonna die like we do a
hilarious prank on their phones like we
text everyone we're like you're gonna
die all right again what company are you
who is this for it's fine we're gonna
tell everyone that uh aliens are
invading and they're gonna kill anyone
who drives in uh Kia Sorrento see guys
this this is why we have these meetings
there's always one of you who wants to
take the joke too far how would I sell
them harambe mattress mere months after
he dies which is something that a
literal company did once yeah no that's
terrible in so many ways I'll sell
Arizona back to Mexico I'll do it I
don't think that's in your jurisdiction
all right you're all cowards you guys
have no fun you have no idea what fun is
I'll just remain the boring old Newman's
Own company really Newman's Own you
don't know me